we wonder  what is enlightenment  it is simply this  right here right now ineffable  perfection that you already  are that we already are this  very reality is a gemstone  this very reality is the  incredible experiential dynamic  play of us of the one  intelligence but to  know yourself as that one intelligence  is what is meant by enlightenment to go  through this so-called veilless  veil or the so-called gateless gate  and to recognize oneself as  the creator to recognize oneself as the  very  emptiness and the very infinitude of  one's  true nature to feel the ecstatic  bliss peace joy  and radiate like the very  sun outward  butterfly affecting the  harmonic vibration of  love of light of unity  of wisdom  when does the sun ask for something in  return  it does not be the very  sun that is enlightenment  thank you